I don't mind watching objectively the
Housewives be train wrecks I've watched
something with your mom if I'm being
honest I don't want to reward Andy Cohen
I'm gonna come on I'm gonna go straight
up and tell you right off I think he's
done more damage or as much damage to
American society as any Entertainer has
ever done I think he shows toxic
women drinking they feed them booze they
pit them against each other he kep CS
train wrecks but it is a it is a
terrible snapshot and it's unfortunate
that it becomes aspirational for other
women yeah and I think he gives one [__]
about them and I think he gives zero
[__] about us or how it has about and I
think he I think he's a pretend good guy
I think those reunion shows he gets
where he gets them yelling at each other
and [__] is just [__] the the the
lowest level form of entertainment and
he pushes it on you like a [__] drug
dealer yeah because he's exploiting
people he is exploiting people and it's
time for it to [__] stop I think he
people I I hear him talking about or
people talking about him being a good
guy but if he he's still cashing checks
and still giving zero [__] and still
putting those people like the the Utah
women out there like I yo you'll never
convince me that he's a good dude I I I
don't know him personally but I think so
I don't know if he's good to his friends
and his family I'm sure he is I think
his value system is [__] yeah just
just a moral compass period I think what
he's doing he knows now when he first
started he didn't know but he knows now
he knows now what how people see it
definitely and and um how it's viewed
and I
think how it's digested by people that
type of entertainment right and I I just
I think with all that [__] I think he he
just as long n as long as I would love
for him to be honest about it be like
yeah dude I actually don't give a [__]
no you know these women get to make
their own choice and they get to come on
and train wreck themselves to death and
I get that that is all true all true but
I think can't you can't act like you're
not exploiting these women yeah yeah
yeah and doing damage to people who are
watching yeah because it's almost like
giving them a false pretense of like
what because the Housewives Are depicted
and help me because I don't really watch
the housewives but are the housewives
depicted of having like this like like
not pristine life but like movie Life
almost like they're depicted of like not
just Rich no they're definitely depicted
as train wrecks and and that they all
have problems but you know what I would
love to see dude but it's almost
glorifying becoming it dude it's
scripted it's scripted TV it's just
unscripted I would love to see a reality
show can you know dude your mom pitched
a reality show with
some with this is how hey women this is
how little faith Network execs have in
you Beth pitched uh reality show in
um Nashville she had these very
successful women in Nashville some wives
of country singers some entrepreneurs
just successful
Multicultural and none of them were
train Rags no okay but the idea of the
show was let's give you the real lives
some of them going through cancer some
divorce some career changes some
problems with their kids and show people
not some they drink sometimes they don't
drink all the time show women supporting
each other and how they get through real
issues of their real life yep and not
one network
exec wanted to show a show and did not
think that anyone would watch a show
where people were dealing dealing with
real problems in their real lives and
real women supporting other real women
that's [__] up yeah and yo dude if you
would pitch that show and we did he she
did Pitch it to a couple networks that
were like yeah we want that and as soon
as I got into development they were like
yeah but can we force drinks on them and
that's Andy
C can we force can we make them look
like [__] train wrecks instead of
grown people who are growing yo dude how
you want drama how much more dramatic is
life and death how much more dramatic is
birth or or troubles with childbirth or
are problems getting pregnant you got to
see this petty ass right and so it's
it's it's a bummer I don't know how we
got off on this but it's a bummer well
you got off on Andy Cohen well not got
off on Andy conen but you know what I
mean yeah and by the way I've met Andy
and was very nice and kind and and um
but but on this on this and I like his I
really do I'll watch that watch what's
happening live yeah um because he seems
like an entertaining dude absolutely but
I think his moral compass is off and he
has enough money in the bank and he
should probably put these [__] shows
to rest yeah yeah it's uh look for him
it's or for other people for the reason
they didn't take mom shows because it's
quote not good TV it's not entertaining
to see something that's not a cat fight
that's why if you see like like that
like those show like baddy South and
like all that stuff it's
like oh my God and and and and it makes
people aspire to being on these [__]
train wreck shows where they're just
going to have to be exploit themselves
and be painted in pictures that they
don't want to be painted in man yeah I
bet you if you asked most most reality
people after the show did you have a
good time was that worth it I bet you a
lot of them would be like yeah it was
that the backlash has been [__]
terrible yeah I mean look look at the
that perfect match show that I worked on
yeah so I I had talked to I still talked
to one of the dudes that was on that
show and even in the middle of it he I
remember him looking at me and going bro
I didn't even know what I signed up for
and after he was like yeah I I can't I
can't do that again I just I can't it's
was it worth it for exposure for me yes
100% but was all of that worth it
because then online for a couple
episodes he was the bad guy and then for
the rest of the show he was the good guy
because people saw it play out the way
it was supposed to play out but it's
like you're at the mercy of those
producers and yeah 100% because uh a lot
of but also a lot of reality stars like
to do something that we call blame it on
the edit yeah you know what I'm saying
and they're like oh that wasn't actually
who I was they edited that is a lot of
that though 100% it is but also at the
same time those people that they're
editing are already that person just
making it blown up more so that
everybody can see it in in what they
would call like a spotlight right like
and let me just say guys it's not that
I'm anti-t train wreck I I love other
people's drama I'm in for I I'm in for a
train wreck every now and then but
balance it out yeah 100% you can't just
constantly be exploiting people's desire
to be famous yeah and making them look
like [__] people and then you get to the
[__] finale and pretend like you're
just you know yeah just a Observer no
dude you push the drinks you push the
story lines yeah 100% 100% yeah reality
it's such a it's such a weird line in
reality TV of of of wanting to like
especially for the the talent on there
wanting to make the
producers and everybody happy and like
you so you can keep a career in this in
the town you know what I'm saying and
like continue to get called for other
things yeah but dude or make the moral
choice like when I talked to this dude
on perfect match I remember talking to
him I was like like dude they're going
to make you they're going to make you
make the TV choice not the right choice
yeah but you have to know that them
making you make the TV choice doesn't
Define who you are as a person but some
people in that in that World start to
make like their right what they think is
their right choice already is that TV
choice and it's like being in that world
with the producers and all that pressure
and the cameras it almost it literally
flips people into just straight reality
stars to where functioning in real life
is difficult yeah yeah I I don't like it
and maybe it is me old me shaking my
fist and get off the lawn but I I I I'm
done with the the the the no Positive
Vibes yeah I'm done I just the reality
show a positive let's let's make a
positive vies reality show though yeah
man but apparently nobody wants to see
it no network wants to put it on anyways
well you know I mean and look dude the
truth of the matter is we're we we're
not attracted to it we're attracted to
the train wreck we're not attracted to
Good News yo dude you know what P pushes
the needle which is why politicians do
it fear not hey yep what's good out
there right now is not what pushes the
needle true what you're scared of losing
what the boogeyman who's coming to get
you yeah that's what pushes the needle
and so and by by the way dude I I'll
tell you man like I you know I I turned
down a reality show for me you your mom
and Kaitlin I know you told me that yeah
I I I'm not not interested I don't know
too many marriages and kids that ended
up on the better after the reality show
do you know what I mean look the osores
maybe are better now but the the two
kids definitely went through some [__]
and I don't know about the the the
Osborne that didn't get filmed I don't
know she has any of the right issues
that the other two had I mean I'm I
can't say that Kardashians got better
but they did get a lot of
money yeah man but you couldn't pay me
to live that life you couldn't pay me to
live that life if you're paying me as
much as they get as much money they have
you could pay there's there's a certain
level you can't pay me no no no because
there is a certain amount of money I
would sell out for and that is up there
with with it for sure Kardashian money
I'm selling out